evan white winning the gold glove award
at first base last year as he sends one
to left center field pretty well hits
draw and brantley converge who wants it
look out
excuse me strong mccormick converge
mccormick and straw run into each other
and everybody seems to be okay
looked like it was getting dangerous
straw was playing over towards that
bright center field side chaz mccormick
coming across
and that eventual collision
as mccormick makes the catch and he got
a glove square to the face
the rookie makes the catch and gets a
glove to the face
that's not the high five i think chaz
was looking for zach was amused
tucker on the go pitches a ball head
first slide by kyle tucker he is saved
second steal of the year for tucker
going on the first pitch against justin
dunn
he was leaning like crazy over there at
first base i'm surprised nobody from the
dugout or on the field even screamed at
him evan white
first baseman
you figure being as close as he was to
him he starts to lean and starts to
twitch a little bit he was going on
first move easy
picked a great pitch to run on too
hit hard to left field base hit tucker
is going to be waved around taylor
trammell's throw coming home tucker's
safe mccormick head first line he's safe
astros laid one nothing on the rbi by
chaz mccormick
he got that hanging breaking ball and
hammered it into left field got beat on
a break i mean a fastball earlier
but able to get the head out
break that into left and we knew early
on this series that omar lopez was going
to test that arm of taylor trammell
not enough to beat powell tucker getting
home
good at bat by chas mccormick
up the middle that's going to be a base
hit mccormick will score easily miles
straw a two strike two out rbi
astros now lead two to nothing
[Applause]
this is a great job by straw fastball
down just shoot it back up the middle
using the entire field
bottom part of the order in action with
two outs to pick up the astros right
here
zach
let's face seven men struck out three
he's on his game yes he is here's a
drive left center field and deep
and it is gone
home run luis terence in the mariners
zone aboard
for luis his first homer of the season
second rbi
well he decided he wasn't going to give
him a free strike first pitch fastball
middle middle and it's crushed exit v
low of 108
426 feet away
[Applause]
jeremy's a chance to do some more damage
yeah they're really starting to do a
number on his pitch count
2-1 pitch
breaking ball fairball down the line
marmillos
on his horse he's going to score manny
waving on tremel and he is he's going to
touch the plate he did there's the ball
is loose
maldonado is hurt and the mariners have
taken the lead
with the scoring tonight the solo home
run and now terrence two-run double so
he's having a great night stays on this
breaking ball keeps it fair just over
the head of bregman marmaleo scores
easily and maniac to being aggressive
with two outs
[Applause]
correa with a strong arm gets there in
plenty of time he's just not able to
handle the throw he just knocks it right
out of there when he steps on him that's
the difference right there he could have
really been hurt
but an aggressive play by tremell going
into home plate he's trying to block the
plate on him and ends up stepping on him
loses the ball he's going to walk a
couple of batteries you need to take
advantage of it terrence able to do that
by staying on the slider that was in the
middle of the plate
j.p hit it hard down the line fair ball
torenzo scores 4-2 mariners
jp crawford with a bullet double
scott service 3-0 lets him swing away
3-0
gets the barrel out in front hits it
down into the corner
pretty good idea you're going to get a
fastball 102 on the exit velo
so for granky somebody that has limited
hitters
getting a barrel to him
it's very calm
got it together here's kyle lewis catch
[Applause]
that kid's gonna win a bunch of gold
gloves great response by dunn posting a
zero in the fourth four two mariners
be like ready to wind up and again the
two two to kyle breaking ball swung on
and a fly ball deep to left field and
this one is gone into the crawford boxes
holy smokes kyle lewis with his second
home run
of the season
straight away left field those crawford
boxes a great target for the
right-handed hitters and it's now the
mariners five and the astros two the
mariners second home run of the night
and number two on the year
for kyle lewis way to go kid
that was absurd how quick that ball got
out didn't take too much time did it
mccormick went back took a look over the
tall wall and it was gone
newly into right center field towards
the bullpen well hit coming back mar
vallejos it's off the wall guerrielle
into second base with a two-out double
six-game hitting streak for yuliy guriel
one of that fastball down but up out
over the plate and yuli takes it and
launches it towards that bullpen in
right field
[Applause]
on the ground past the diving shortstop
crawford in the left field that'll be an
rbi base hit for carlos correa
two out single for the astros all their
runs coming with two out tonight it's
now five to three
cutter down and away stays on it
and is able to rip that past jp crawford
and get that two-out rbi
astros showing a pulse
initially i thought crawford might be
able to keep it on the infield out of
two
[Applause]
ground ball right side white has it
he'll make the play though he throws it
away coming in the score tucker it's a
one-run game
the goals lover evan white throws it
away
and the astros in business down one
carlos trying to shoot it the other way
and
delivery to jp crawford wide left
just yanked it
see if the astros can continue to take
advantage
now only one run down
[Applause]
there's a ball into left center field
yulia is headed to third he'll be waved
around here comes the throw cut off
we're tied at five
the astros are breaking some egos right
here fastball up
stay on it
great job by olynys diaz
not a bad read by eule either
to be able to score from second on that
player
outside ball four astros take the lead
on the bases loaded walk
to jason castro to forcing her on
into right field
hagerty just moved out to right field
diaz is tagging and coming home the
throw will not be in time seven to five
game altuve a sacrifice fly everybody
moves up a base
ground ball right side jose altuve is
there
ball game over big comeback for the
astros with four in the bottom half of
the eighth inning